Happy New Year's guys I like tired as
[ __ ] either way the Rat King is in
Europe right now so we're taking a
little break
but we will be back on January 23rd with
a brand new episode for that ass giving
a little update on Chin's chinder date
huh with Carly I think that's her name I
think I called her Carl hot Carl either
way you get the update on that brand new
episodes we wanted to thank you guys for
tremendous 2019 and we promise 2020s
coming bigger badder and a whole lot
drip here so thank you guys tune in come
back January 23rd and we thank you Gang
Gang buzz-buzz ha ha Kalina
get your life together touch me bro I'm
not touching
and oh what the [ __ ] is your aunt's name
chin in it what is it Hana aunt Anna and
Hana Hana any god damn it Hanna with all
respect King bro give it up give it up
give it up with your sweats Bronco Tony
I [ __ ] your new chin nose hole now dude
your aunt you [ __ ] some houses and
this is no disrespect zero bro is she
single
now she's not saying she's married to
your uncle snared mom they have kids
they got kids you're [ __ ] right they
do look at that mommy leave that [ __ ]
mommy she a blood aunt yeah damn she's
quran's this part a little bit of green
in there god damn I bet I'd chop it down
bro [ __ ] right you would oh I'd share
a [ __ ] double scoop orange chicken
with her and talk about things
oh I karate kick her right into my bed
bro what I'm talking about is she seemed
like a nice lady dude I'd watch a
marathon of [ __ ] The Last Samurai
with her with my dick out flaunt my aunt
yeah this is all good these are
compliments where did she go to school
at Harvard in Texas
I've never heard of it Harvard well
there's a lot of schools in Texas and
there's a lot of not schools in Texas um
she looks like a nice lady did she
bartend or not I think was younger she
[ __ ] right she's obviously made Bank
bro what's your uncle look like it's a
curricular dude
oh yeah the Asian or not is he is is he
out kicking his coverage kicking this
coverage yeah yeah like yeah he's a
lucky dude I'd say he's pretty lucky
that he looks like [ __ ] Jesus he's lucky
my uncles it look like [ __ ] over there
it's flaunt you're on
yes say something nice about the diving
and I've been dating a lot [ __ ] behind
her at a bar no I did it you asked if
she weren't if she [ __ ] could put
tequila together
does she drink a lot I don't [ __ ]
know she does she go to a lot of raves
she do a lot of ecstasy on the weekends
[ __ ] I don't know man but she looks like
she's down down to hang out and have a
good time
yeah she's how old is she yeah that's a
good question I think maybe in like mid
40 mm thing about Asians bro you me get
you an agent deal you cannot tell they
don't age but then 80 comes boom
Cinderella
father time they age like fruit oh they
disappear tonight they turn into a
yellow squash but I'll say this dude
whoo chanting 40s if not know Jesus and
we shot a body watching it seemed like
she was in the gold rush or something
she has a very you know kind of
authentic sort of look kind of you know
her hair used to be like up here the
Texas big Texas hair
so she's trimmed it down a little bit
but it's still high she's a she's a
little bit of southern twang to that
Texas twine sure man honey cause her own
honey she looks like she me makes a mean
[ __ ] bit c-stand grazie she makes
such good food and food rescue see that
there she makes brisket the best this is
wifey son
how many kids uh three and they're all
your age now no they're younger oh yeah
I could see that damn she seemed like
somebody that would get water from the
river and like just no medicine does she
know anything about medicine or
medicines
she would say she gives a natural cures
looks like she gives a good back rub and
then reads [ __ ] tarot cards she's
strong
oh dude let that lady beat the [ __ ] out
of me me too does she know Conklin she
knows her condo probably a little
[ __ ] knew it man she looks like it
broke a handle herself
oh I'd let her run over me with a car
until I came dude I would I would share
a full rack of ribs with a Chili's
wouldn't give a [ __ ] yeah she seemed
like a nice lady and a melon she seemed
super nice yeah flaunt my art flop my
art shout out to chins on shut up -
[ __ ] Nix grandma for the sidekick
there right the aunt just got out shine
shopping it's grandma bro hey dude I
think we got a segment here though bro
okay I got height for your family bro I
got high for your family bro
no I can't think about chins out and mix
grandma bro I just want Nick and chin to
make it out of here safely thank God me
too I want the same DNA like the worst
Power Ranger really yeah you look like
the non-athletic Power Ranger you look
like the only Power Ranger that can't
fight using cost you your power Angela
does a book bag you gave the Power
Ranger that wants to talk about it power
bottom Ranger dude everybody's fighting
has head per 200 [ __ ] just dancin over
the only brown power color not the
hashtag no races you got you okay I got
to [ __ ] jump ropes backwards only
dude bro backward oh there's no brown no
nuts dude bro you look like a [ __ ] I
look like a shower Ranger okay the only
one that that really needs a shower you
might have a ridiculous ass but you
always have baggy clothes on we don't
know you're right just like Roseanne
[Laughter]
Texas where you look like really
O'Donnell's side piece and you guys have
the same stylist one of the Loom
characters that just shows up on drugs
like everybody else is like the red line
the red strawberry the the green line
I'm Anna and you're the [ __ ] banana
that [ __ ] left home early
you you look like one of those people
from breaking Amish that leaves and
[ __ ] comes back a week later all 10
just experienced everything in one
anyone we got a great topic
you got 60 tats what a bunch of bad
shirts a couple fake rollies and
suddenly you don't know how to use a
shovel anymore Sammy Sosa's lotion give
some [ __ ] shrimp so smoking
cigarettes don't get a shrimp get
everyone here shrimp I'm trying to quit
smoking cigarettes and you look like
bubble lump dude you think but you look
like someone broke into your body and
just sprayed a bunch of [ __ ] drywall
in your sheet you look like security a
city boy but he look like your whole
face is soundproof dude okay you can get
ass bestest poisoning from your own fat
cells you dress like you only fly in
spirit anyway I'll give you that but you
have the most frequent flyer miles on
Spirit Airlines dude Spears crazy one
guy didn't have a seat that is tide of
river wall just hang on my bus
[Music]
dude he's like a fat ambulance that
didn't make the [ __ ] sports team at
school yeah dude
howdy partner he's hella game feels like
9 tires on it and all of them are kind
of flat gets on peds for hiding your
sigmund you definitely think like that
dude why are you hiding over there Bob
where the horses get their medicine well
how are you hiding my mom's beets well
yeah I can't tell just Brook have one
black guy
look it's crossdresser Oh Brooke is a
man yes no no no no no and let's take
that part out actually can we do that
yeah I want to come for command but also
yeah let's also decide first we look at
Brooke again dude that Brooke is a fine
young aunt and it says she can you look
can you look for another second I will
say this I don't wanna get ahead but
contest with her that's all I'll say
yeah I'll say this Brooke it says flaunt
my aunt yeah if I had this aunt dude I
would definitely let her babysit me dude
worst Pete my uncle yeah Oh dudes get
these aunts all the goddamn time
throwing it uncle every now and then we
want no we're looking at women you I
know I'm just saying Pete my uncle don't
out yourself do your friends and family
is supposed to do that dude you stopped
smoking cigarettes and your day now I
think we should celebrate it by peeping
uncle's their side effects on the
packaging you and I whatever will you
tell us some stuff about this beautiful
lady we didn't think about this she
works in a doll factory favorite food is
chocolate-covered bananas
Chandler's wants them to be the one to
break Theo out of his slump
oh he's in that she oh she wants to be a
slump-buster what's her name
Oh Brooke I'm looking cam right here
Brooke you know I get to the cheese
gotta go through the beat oh hey Brenda
with a first successful rhyme of 2019
Hey unbelievable only took him six 17
episode although on Brooke
my friends gay now so we got to figure
it out
yep I'm gay you'll know it all right you
idiot better bring cigarettes girl you
better bring cigarettes touch me bro
don't touch me bro I'm Charlotte aunt
Brooke I'm not met her favorite food
chocolate bananas okay what do you think
of that D what are you trying to imply
there I'm just saying I'd like it well
their opinion I don't like it it's
basically it's a banana in blackface and
I think that it's wrong
I don't you guys have ever seen it or
not I didn't want to say it don't I
don't want saying I feel like the little
racist
yeah now our dark chocolate banana is
really it's good that is that is pretty
good the Mel what do you think Derek
what do you think about this dime right
here I'm one sense with that mascara on
her eye she looks like one of those
girls from the point of videos with the
mascara right yeah the [ __ ] girls um
yes is she holding a cookie or is that
slice of pizza
what's he'd say you know it is pizza is
that Pete's are we sure is this Dave
Portnoy in a freaking disguise ma'am no
God man why is she uh
why'd she have a Barbie thing uh what's
going on here what what do you mean she
works at a doll factory oh she works at
a doll factory so make my factory mm-hmm
bother said a dog factor what is that
what is Petsmart
Oh like a puppy mill what where do you
live it in your head dog Factory
again Oh Brooke you want to get to the
honey you gotta go through B you [ __ ]
up your own life get up well I'm talking
full light on cigarettes I need
cigarettes
look I say Brooke got them front cookies
man than hitters them tits and uh and if
this is a real aunt because there's a
lot of stuff going on here she's got
that mask area like your boy said Derek
zoom in on that I hold the [ __ ] dude
there's [ __ ] all over no one's noticed
this at semen in it she's not a [ __ ]
Simmental is she I think deal for this a
man dude that's not a band she's making
a porno and this is the end of it you
know what don't cut out the part I said
in the beginning because I was trying to
be go back to this look at the whole
thing on here the blonde hair doesn't
match the rest of her hair this is a
man's face and he got busted on he must
be off cigarettes
oh god [ __ ] he's off secrets
he worked at a doll factory this is a
young fella man this is a twice young
man who enjoys pizza and getting loads
on his face well who knows it I'm a
detective
I think 48 I Hey okay so you're a
detective dude you're the worst attack
in six minutes praise in this young lass
dude what do you tell he said a couple
nice tits I'm out taking her out for a
good time first thing I said was that
this young fella running the cameras see
the [ __ ] scene on this dude or what
is this sir turned into man I don't want
to be a part of anything like this man
yeah let's not well let's put this on
this town but I ain't doing this stuff
when I'm looking at semen on some fellow
man it might be sweat though any sweat
that's thick dick sweat over somebody's
nuts it is dude I'm serious man we can
do it this time I'm not looking at this
kind of stuff I didn't come here to look
at this you're the next one Derek's your
mother weren't you looking at the [ __ ]
no she would not she wouldn't like it
Jesus all right dude this is Austin
Pollard be tough to beat that one yeah
nobody has a rap name which is weird
they're all given we'll give them rap
let me hear him oh he looks like he has
beads that's a little browse bro browse
up hoes down down
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're [ __ ] a little scramble you got
to apologize this guy you win its are
[ __ ] sick dude or else pay a lot of
money look that's not clown in bars do
those really just little browse for
great do I'm little thick
what's up dude maybe the first guy sign
- ah oh I thought you meant tow truck
like death row row yeah dude with a
little more death a lot more row you
feel me can turned a little bit of a
chin [ __ ] put his cheese away the
cheese should say go on you like a sharp
cheddar yeah
how many of them look it's can still
only name sharp cheddar I know chin yeah
you know Brenda was hoping to pull a
different cheese out of his brain I love
cheese than you you cannot brush yes I
can do it right now right now I'll go
then you go ready oh he gets to start
with here you go ready Swiss bro i
provolone baby parmesan nobody else dude
that's what I'm saying
Karma's on let me see yakety yak
pepperjack sharp cheddar
what was just going we're going serial
killer cheese bro let me go with that
breyer boy about that Becky brie is that
a real thing baking for his retreat he's
gonna break in that one real trees
nature God dude sometimes I got the
rhythm and sometimes I got the blue
cheese
[Applause]
he's good and he's bad because I'm
[ __ ] what's over that mile chatter
that sweet red chatter I got chatters
all day rather sweet red [ __ ] that's
that's real that's real that's real I
buy it
it's from England it's a sweet rich
other foods dude right there sweet red
oh no no that's a type of cello
I promise protecting it the company's
called something else
oh you scroll in sweet red LLC right now
scroll in that's a company's called
somerdale or something like that
somerdale sweet red cheddar suck this
real cheese though yeah that's all I buy
it's another chatter oh it's another
different type if we had to go the
judges I don't know guys let's go to the
cheese Chinese over here what are we
doing raising somebody let me alone how
about Asiago [ __ ] cheese Mulligan
this is a type of cheese I've just given
out for while you're still [ __ ]
Scooby red touch a cheese that's a
[ __ ] hookers a nickname huh that's a
real cheese bro you don't need your
cheese I'll see I'll go for the win
that's your mom calling you give you
more ideas no it was yellow off ask him
Oh yellow cheddar yellow how about give
us something dude or real [ __ ]
slipped on some what was that Oh cream
cheese
[Applause]
[Music]
is that a real cheese okay I mean that's
the thing man it's like we getting you
know is it a real cheeseburger cheese
that counts that's behind uh I don't
know if it does but is it a just a style
of cheese you know we kind of know our
cheese's though don't we
ah I don't know I can't remember if you
said this one or not just play it that
bad mother mozzarella hmm if we played
that one Davey or not I don't think
Stella and I got announces now I'm going
are you I got that [ __ ] Oh
string cheese
drinking that's a band band okay [ __ ]
what it is type of cheese that's all I
know that string let's move on Doug did
know what 20 minutes go over Jean yeah
you did six on your ass you go with
sweet rad from England bro
chin you like a sharp cheddar check that
[ __ ] out all right up next a little
advice for Mark banks from Iowa mark the
spark baby blaze it up Gang Gang
buzzbuzz buzzbuzz gobble-gobble Aysen
tschappat bang I've been married for 25
years
oh you're [ __ ] I'm great help me get
through sorry I'm still dealing with
some [ __ ] so I been smoking some weed
and I got caught before doing then she
wasn't happy about it but clearly in a
shed I thought it'd help so I started
again and I haven't told her yeah she
told me last time that I should tell her
before I try to do anything like this
and you agree to that so question is
should I tell her it seems to help with
anxiety
or should I just keep on keeping on Oh
PS Brendan Schaub you're the coolest
[ __ ] on this planet right now
love you man whoa obviously you your dad
dude you gotta give me better contact
with your parents man because are you
bad dude you [ __ ] tits McGee let's
mark the spark bro and that he loved
that dude that dudes blazing eyes
blazing blazing he's so high he's
hitting on you from a shed behind his
house while his wife is a hottie shed
hot [ __ ] right there dude I love your
shadow play the very end again where he
talks really says I'm not going bad on
him Oh PS Brendan Schaub you're the
coolest [ __ ] on this planet
right now
love you man pretty cool man what a nice
it is a nice guy man
smoking the weed here's the thing if it
helped you especially in 2019 right
correct
barely uh who gets mad that someone
smoking weed especially anxiety your
girl's not down with it man then she's
not she's not the one now I don't know
if you're getting high know what this is
and now he's finding out 25 years later
bro you'd still make mistakes I would
definitely tell her I would 100% tell
her and she's not cool with it she ain't
the 125 years bro oh my god this guy
thought you were cool too divorce what
are you saying then what do you think
they're just gonna live down my street
from each other while he smokes weed yes
some of it and if he makes you better
who's gonna hate on so it makes you a
better person
well that's a good point I think but I
think he's told the wife that he would
let her know if he was gonna smoke and
he didn't so for some reason he likes
keeping it a secret I think it's like
it's like the one thing he can do that's
like oh that his wife doesn't know about
so he must find some joy in that yeah
it's kind of sneaky yeah he likes to
have something of his own which i think
is okay
I mean by not hurting anybody right
you're not hurting anybody not her you
just said jacking off the porno in this
shed and getting high right
I keep getting high man yeah we do and
if she says you know she catches you
then fess up to it and say look there
you know and then just tell her the
truth whatever the reason is why you
wanted to keep getting high I wanted to
keep getting high because I liked doing
something that you don't know about you
know I like getting high makes my
anxiety better
dude I'll tell you about this if you're
gettin high and you got a wife a little
bit of weed to make your wife feel like
a brand-new woman you know take the sex
to a different place yeah she's
complaining about weed to get her high
and then eat her ass like groceries you
know I'm saying 25 years mix it up bro
give it up give it up give what up dude
life advice don't do it concisely huh oh
my god let's go to cat and get a woman's
perspective I can't even live right here
25 years bro keep smoking that hitter
you just give the guy 9 different pieces
of advice man I'm hoping some sticks
do a lot of things
and I hope he connects to one he's like
you know I'm gonna get her high and eat
her ass I'm hoping that one sticks now
yeah you blow a little weed smoke in the
bedroom or something maybe booty all
right but you could take her on that
tour but you know just you need to be a
liaison there with her you need to like
you know hit or hi and leave her in the
other room for a half-hour you know and
sneak around the house and ring a bell
dude no no don't scare don't don't don't
get her hi and play [ __ ] the
conjuring you know the same I'll tell
you this after cats a suggestion cat
what do you think well why doesn't she
like like I'm smoking weed if it helps
with anxiety she never see before I mean
maybe she should get it on the smoking
that's a cat and see or it could just be
something that he does away from her if
it helps him or Chur naughty little
secret yeah I mean who's he hurting dude
we had this kid named Caleb right and so
we got so high one time one of us he was
about to leave so somebody snuck out and
took his steering wheel off his car
right so then dude he goes out to his
car bro
and he was open for like seven minutes
and he comes back inside and he's like
ah you can tell he's kind of nervous to
tell us you know he's like man I can't
find my steering wheel right and
everybody's like oh you are [ __ ] high
bro you're an idiot you know you're a
psychopath you know cause people just
throw that in you know and haha
and dude so we laughed for like 10
minutes Oh even he was laughing at the
fact I can't find my steering wheel
right so in the meantime that guy went
back out and put his steering wheel back
into his car right so then we all go out
there as a group and the skin was back
on bro any [ __ ] loss oh hi bro lost
his mind you check himself in a mental
health center and it's still there still
in the health center in 28 years 29
years so is that nature or nurture you
know it seemed to work out for him well
it's I don't know it's it's kind of a
bigger discussion but but what I'm
saying do it is look get high bro you in
the shed you getting high I think you
secretly want to get busted by your lady
I think it adds a little bit of spark a
little bit of spice to your life dude
say get high get your lady in there get
blunted together and send us another
video and yeah and tell us what's going
on I want to send that Blair Witch sex
tape in the shed or just sent a nice
video introducing us to your lady that
worked
yeah like shoutout to this dude yeah
mark the spark baby blaze up dude I want
to see you get heated and play off
fluffy bunny to where you fill your
mouth with marshmallows bra puffs give
to yourself yeah I might uh buddy -
asking about investing in a zoo actually
in Mexico in Sinaloa hugs in there
Sinaloa
yeah oh man they don't have any issues
out there you should definitely do that
well some of its beachside I think if
you look it up I don't know I don't know
if the end of the visa I know a cartel
would be the main issues there that's
why they need people to come in and do
this hold up you think you're opening a
zoo and sanella Mexico and you don't
think gotta grease the palms the cartel
there bro you think you're bringing in
zebras and you bought the vet these are
you think you'll have to grease the
palms of the underworld you think you're
bringing a bearded lizard pass out chapo
and you don't have to grease the [ __ ]
palms daddy got your goddamn I'm bro
dude I look don't worry it's not I don't
know a buddy am I got a read on an
animal investor gotta dude get a read
and open it somewhere close to us man
all investigate well 4800 to get in bro
can you give me any information to Eric
give a lot of Luis is here but can help
him out Louis Wow how do these races
right told me you were yesterday what
are you what are you what are you Louise
I [ __ ] called it dude didn't call
anything son whose native Amer
you kept calling Mexican I did my
respecting them and just kept it very
lucky man yeah Latino yeah do you know
whatever Darrell yeah whatever dude it
says but either way he'll I'm from
Mexico he knows it's a bad idea open up
any
see America okay have some respect
battle bro
you open up up [ __ ] petting zoo there
either you know saying it a petting zoo
you ask well it's a sanctuary for
anomalies will you give us some
information Derek it's apparently not
safe to be there for foreigners very
risky and don't be out at night the most
words well maybe the most risky
Americans can't go there and your dumb
ass try and open up all white people
zoom it's a dating zoo zoo it's not a
night this seems like a [ __ ] cover-up
for sex trafficking that's what it
sounds like
su-mei comes who's a horrible idea
animals get frisky dude what do you want
otherwise these animals are gonna be
coming up here looking for her who's bro
we need to take care of these animals on
their home court hit up Whitney Cummings
[Laughter]
quality's bad today if you have a hippo
let me know I'll bring my truck I'll be
at the corner of Highland and last yet
again night taking all emus and larger
that's what her oh sit please no snakes
dude here's our own scenes you know Lola
beautiful day time you need is there any
images if you click on Sinaloa how about
this first thing that pops up showered
in a blaze of bullets you're not open to
their [ __ ] click on an image you know
you should do oh but what we're gonna
[ __ ] petting zoo in Syria right now
dude hey this isn't the spot hold on I
do want to open up actually a a company
like a cling-wrap company in Syria calls
Syrian wrap no we do whatever dude well
listen to this man animals deserve love
everywhere and I think do it then 48
Hyundai you know and I know it's
expensive but to know that animals are
doing well there and however then one of
the whole city's on fire which one you I
bond right in the middle oh that's where
they're looking Elmer people that down
like that one oh it's just a bunch of
dead bodies that's a bunch of dead
bodies ever-present River
yeah it's time oh there's to know when
the mix is most violent states but you
know what makes people relax and calm
down guinea pigs
see honey Molly's anomalous oh look at
the sheep I made your guns away man
forget the drugs today Holmes yeah I
like lambs steel Vaughn's camera over
here bro bro
ooh look the Rat King have a [ __ ] a
porcupine up here what'd you find at the
awesome man
well look man sorry I want to invest in
Mexico dude knows how it happens people
want to invest in Mexico they get turned
down by a guys wearing the Eagles jacket
but doesn't want to support Eagle asal
is a--
what about the O do I like my flamingo
hey are there Eagles in Mexico Mexican
Eagles look it up Mexican eagle nope
bald eagle I would assume he's the
America's logo because of you can only
get him here unlike any Bradford I found
throughout the world the bald eagles
found only only in North America you
[ __ ] get so goddamn red white and
blue only found in North America dude
that's there that's the Mexican eagle
right there no hold up it says the ball
don't hold up the bald eagle only found
in North America bald eagles are found
throughout most of the North America
from Alaska Canada how fantastic that
nope I didn't see that other part hey
guys my name's Christians [ __ ]
Livermore California huge fan of both
you guys but I got a question for you
guys so I got a man bun my question for
Theo is man bun vs. mullet its Edna
mullets ha that's hot all right thanks
Thank You Christian
howdy Christian Wow so crazy that was
his name
Christian wonder who sent that name in
right on the very next question and
wonder if it was maybe the Lord maybe
the Lord strikes down upon us yeah you
know it feels right about Christmas yeah
kidding it nope um listen man man buns
are we're a fad unless you're a Japanese
samurai it's tough to have a man bunny
but where you cannot jewelry though in a
man bun you cannot Jules if you get high
some order
but it took to rock a mullet like back
in the day everyone was doing it
but to do it now I mean that is a big
dick energy move you know I'm thinking
it's not you you know you can get some
[ __ ] for it unless you're in the inner
circle unless you're a fan of Theo
you're in the circle of fighting the kid
and the squad people are gonna celebrate
you but outside in the real world you
take heat for everything but yeah
they're coming I think you can't be
around my kid if you have a mullet like
we had before you came over Thanksgiving
we had a huge discussion really should
we allow a man I went listen I know I'm
pretty well and every day just kept
saying he has a mullet he has a mullet I
know and we were torn it somebody just
showed up and he just showed I'm like
well [ __ ] it
well ma let's just show up dude you
don't expect them dude a lot of times
cancer patients you know what's wild is
when God regrows their hair it starts at
the very back and grows long there first
o Instron I'm never seen that and so a
lot of you don't know that if you the
first one of the first steps of beating
cancer first signs you're beating cancer
is your body starts to sprout a mullet
and that's pretty fascinating and that's
that's a plus that's science that's
science and also though and two people
that I like most on this earth you and
Dog the Bounty Hunter
both have [ __ ] mullet both of the
same style dogs I'll shout out to the
stylist that can fly to Hawaii cut his
[ __ ] fly here cut your [ __ ] whoo so
you're single ready to mingle yeah yeah
can you use a term that's not from 1970
Brendan hey real quick ask her about the
weather again Dorcas Mallorca --the
ascetic winter
delinquent let me talk for a second yeah
go ahead good afternoon
um do you um
have you ever spent time around uh
someone like Chan before him evasion oh
this is not a good start
what's your usual that counts you know
um what's your usual type like what type
do you go for
I guess there's like kind of like a
variety but I think probably mostly
white guys mm-hmm what about off-white
sure that way okay and do you what do
you how done dog how is your experience
been on the dating scene has it been a
bit of a nightmare or I mean your your
pretty girl thank you single so I mean
but that's not your fault I hope not
but you also enjoyed do you like being
single I mean it's kind of fun right
periods of it but yeah I think it's fun
I mean you don't have to worry about
yourself well what was the last date you
went on are you a serial dater do you
date a lot no no I merely go on and
where do you usually meet these men like
which one like yeah are we talking like
tinder we talking Mambo farmers only
are you on farmers only I knew it I know
it there's a lot of people infiltrated
it it's not it's not only farmers and
the problem other people were getting on
there yeah do you like to go to the gym
you said what else do you enjoy doing
ma'am young let it yeah yes yes sorry
yeah sorry young lady concerts and you
and you're headed to work now I'm going
to be shortly yeah and where are you
working these days I work at an agency
gotcha hmm sounds professional and and
that last date you went on what did you
guys do like you ever give us the idea
of the date you run on
oh nice can I go [ __ ]
then you got what oh I'm sorry
the line cut out and I say oh wow
have you ever made love to a kind of a
troubled kind of Asian guy made love to
H to an Asian gentleman decent guy okay
your first one and chin likes this chin
likes this and do you think that you
have do you think that a lot of Asian
guys hit on you usually or do you feel
invisible to them or what do you feel
like but you probably don't encounter a
lot of Asians I'm just gonna go on a
limb but you got some flavor with that
yeah I can see that you got some flavor
with that nose piercing so I'm assuming
you get all sorts of comers what sorry
my friend is uh ha not very wise look
let's be honest with each other how far
do you think you see you and Chin's
future going can they start a date first
dude and then take it from there
no one knows we have no idea yeah he's
like a missing person that's alive yes
that's exact
sorry my friends had his own issues of
dating um yeah I think you guys need God
Aten feel have you ever seen chin do you
know what he looks like
yeah and your and your friend submitted
you for this yeah and does your friend
what did she say you you're gonna love
this guy or this guy seems like a real
kind of a sort of a hero like a
middle-aged hero or what did she what
did she say
what were the he is my enemy oh here's
my book remaining voyage and he was what
and what college did you go to I own oh
hell yeah lbc girl lbst actually she's
in the LBC though awesome you're brave I
like your attitude I like your attitude
to what would be a perfect date for you
[Music]
I love red wine okay Jim write this down
okay done a winery mm-hmm I see nap in
your future okay okay here well he just
wrote down red vines so if you get a
bunch of movie candy people know what's
going on let her finish her date though
so Cain has more so wrestling what else
sorry talkative person yeah I'm thinking
that like not like a movie where you're
just sitting there and quiet yeah it
makes no sense
I prefer like activities like fun things
mm-hmm competitive okay easygoing yep
easygoing you ever gonna [ __ ] fights
before no and I look I'm not saying it's
legal everywhere but I'm not saying it's
also not a wise change yeah a lot of
we're asking for it yeah you can't get
far after that as well yeah yeah it
could be a nice night well look we would
love to treat you guys to a nice night
out wherever that is and do something
special for you guys and um we don't
know what that's gonna be exactly yet
but we have a nice budget for it and we
want to eat you to do something fun if
you're willing to take our friend out
who also is willing to take you out
I like your style girl your boys always
like this or do you have a cold I like
it ranges I had a hole any party over
the weekend yeah yeah girl we all do a
blow or anything like that or what were
you guys up to
ah just a late night it was for my
company party drugs to urge us alcohol
do you fancy drugs at all you partake in
any drugs
I like your attitude
Wow yeah you seem like a great lady seem
fantastic I mean things don't work out
can you and chin I I got a friend who
looks like meg Ryan that might be a yeah
leave me alone
Brendan I'm throwing you alley-oops here
dude and you slept no you seem like a
great guy you seem awesome well I think
maybe you send us some date you're
available we'll get with Qin scheduled
Han let me check yeah he's available
so then hey man Thank You Derek for
being at least trying to be respectful
to everyone I'm trying to we got some
relationship advice
this is Angela from Spring Oklahoma oh
she sounds beautiful
Oh chest
snakes in the front my guy that I was
with for two years
your robot we just recently broke up ah
constantly cheated
oh he's not the only one every guy
before him that I've been with has felt
the need to wander off yeah it doesn't
matter what I do
keeping up with the house making sure
foods on the table keeping up with my
cells the night always come back hold on
it's sorry Brennan wants to starve at
home obviously the start over let's go
back to the middle this lady's house was
on the table house is spotless I don't
see much when he walks she's just
holding the mail she's like tell me what
it says
I don't educate myself housewife this is
what she likes to do be at home do
recipes take care of the house take care
of the kids
[Laughter]
like I'm gonna Dave & Buster's and the
power's out brother still played all the
games he's still kicking the ticket
machine wonder why the tickets aren't
coming out who cares why they're not
coming out it takes 70,000 tickets to
get a damn whistle you idiot all right
let's let this poor lady finish okay I
don't what I do
keeping up with myself making sure
things say exciting we're playing in the
bedroom there yeah but they always come
back that's the thing oh oh so I'm just
wondering what makes them want to wander
in the first place
tell me something good
buzz buzz buzz buzz my housewife I think
he said buzz bus that they could be on
the end of it
oh you broke me you start this been
after you condemn this lady's lifestyle
I'd love to see how you gonna dig
yourself out of shovels in the front do
dig yourself out of this [ __ ] hole you
put yourself in Devils in the front
shovels in the bag man they always come
back
I don't know man maybe they take her for
granted and they're just not trying to
[ __ ] with or maybe she's just too good
no I got she might be overwhelming
it's not like she'll have her own [ __ ]
going on get a hobby get less tattoos
you know I'm saying well you don't like
it - to Brendan we'll all do that we'll
just stop getting a maybe although I
think they're sexy okay then while you
say that Dan she is from a spring
Oklahoma who sprung out there doing that
Brokeback [ __ ] and then come back after
the up to those storm well that's a no
that's a not even a good idea I don't
think but what I will say is this and
I'm sorry it's a good idea but I just
don't think that that's accurate
what I'm thinking is if these guys are
leaving well maybe y'all have too many
doors on your house or apartment you
know Tom I've taken people prisoner know
if people can get out easily yeah don't
think I'm prisoner but don't put four
doors on your house but here's man be
upset if your spouse leaves they [ __ ]
get out he's confused yeah you won or I
don't even do a back door you come in
the front you go out the front one door
doors in the front doors in the front
we're making so many goddamn pies sounds
like she's cooking all the time maybe
it's overwhelming for the dude maybe you
need to mix it up start going out on him
we're making apple pies cherry pies
rhubarb pecan pumpkin Oh one pie a week
one pie a week Netflix and chill
she seems like an older soul does she
nope do you know you are just a real
strange guy man come on bro don't touch
me do not touch let me do touching her
hot look I think maybe I don't know what
do you guys think let's go to cab maybe
let's get a woman perspective let's also
talk to Derrick as well you know oh yeah
dude I mean definitely she's providing
way too much to these guys yeah do that
especially when you're younger they get
too comfortable start taking you for
granted how old is she
capsulate how old is she yeah if you're
19 homeboys coming and got a
seven-course meal you dressed like a 50s
housewife and you got [ __ ] you know
yet you hold you you're doing too much
you're scaring everybody away it sounds
like you're just going out the alley and
one of those seven doors you have in
your house yeah I'm a little fun easy
yeah maybe uh yeah I don't know okay
she may be chasing guys who just aren't
ready to settle down the same way she is
- she's hot
yeah that's true he's young maybe she's
ready for something that younger guys
around her age aren't ready for older
soul exactly dee would he think I think
she definitely hooks up with a lot of
dudes who attract a lot of girls so stop
dead [ __ ] a Seth Rogen looking
[ __ ] yeah who's gonna be
grateful ladies look at you you know
what I mean and I bet that problem is
done and then if that guy cheats on you
then it's definitely you you know what I
mean read a book or something you think
it get ugly dude Shades of Grey I'm sure
you're [ __ ] the same guy over and
over again and that's why they keep
cheat you talking about that bad boy
hitter that boy well doesn't that pipe
game yeah there's a whole spectrum to
you if you get a guy that's all about
looks or something like that then you
might you know you know it might not get
a guy that as much harder as much like
you know gratitude or anything like that
so you got to kind of even the scale out
it's like if you get a ten and looks
then they're gonna be a seven and some
you know it's all it's all relative it's
all evens out you know you want that's
why you want to get that eight you want
to find an eight the hard a that
they don't go for the ten [ __ ] boy yeah
yeah eight Tianna day get that date yeah
date an eight day mate cuz everybody can
be an eight here's the thing everybody
can be an eight if they take care of
themselves believe that but I like read
I liked how positive you are an eight
and eight you know I'm saying anybody
can be a five put in eight no if you
brush your teeth and you and you I think
have you know a little bit of insight
right yes I'm most self-awareness as
that's well you know I think a high she
can be as a six
damn yeah God doesn't give me one good
looks bro trust me I know dude I know
you know okay look what you've done with
your stuff dude I'm cross-eyed but both
of them are in the st. they're both the
straight cross yeah yeah you like a
chameleon
yes crossed on the inside on the outside
it looks fine shut up to this things I
hope she figures out quit [ __ ] with
them [ __ ] boys though that's the problem
well I don't know if we we didn't help
that woman I feel like we did though
like a DJ at a rave right dude you look
[ __ ] Wyatt slurp bro you look like a
cop at a freaking bathhouse dude DJ at a
rave
[ __ ] dip slow you not telling good
joke almost didn't even listen to that
bro you Sheriff [ __ ] transgender
lemonade my cowboy there's a snake in my
butt you like you're like Steve Irwin
but the gay you look like the first NASA
astronaut who's transgender gonna space
oh dude it's a big leap on going only
for mankind I'm going straight into
somebody's wiener bro
yeah then they take off their helmets
and it's five lesbians dude yeah there
were cuts yeah
did I be a lesbian bro here's that
here's why be a lesbian one I thought
you were you can still wear the same
[ __ ] you were did you were this exact
outfit definitely like you're their mask
I'm not Brendan your crazy brother
where'd you read that you picked your
outfit out from that place where you
trade in tickets at Dave and Buster's
dude you look like a lifeguard of a
junkyard
[Laughter]
you look like Patrick Swayze got kind of
tanning bed you look like Patrick Swayze
[Laughter]
twinks dude you look like Kevin Bacon's
we grew up in Chernobyl that's what the
tattoo looks like where'd you get the
head in a Lion King gift shop that
people are ruling they go in dangerous
people are basically in the woods
chanting you're the last one who like
won a row you look I got Eclair that
Romeo Crennel had for breakfast you look
like you've been through some things but
are you doing okay I'm fantastic who are
you again what costume is it dude I'm
woody and your buzz light gear never
heard of either one of them okay it's
not know what you are dude it is just
really alarming dude you just think
you're an astronaut do you look like
Dallas a returners Club dude like
somebody got a refund yeah look like
you're going through some stuff brah no
Mira I can't see my outfit dude no you
look warm you look sweet dude maybe you
and Brennan this is Tanner from Fable
Arkansas who damn pig I'm one of the 30
people in the state who have internet so
I'm using it to ask this question
it would survive longer imprison between
you two Shang Shang that might be a
shirt Oh No hold somebody's pocket and
something that mouth warm with smooth
creamy peanut butter they said it would
take of my own 600 years I got out of
there say a prison time but burnish I've
did it in less than 16 right yes in the
problem is let's go be let's don't lie
that Derek isn't Morgan Freeman's son
first of all look like Morgan Freeman
bro who would last longer in prison I
think we gotta go to the culture corner
man because white people are definitely
me I'm imprisoned in an all-time high
right now so and like I can't join the
white supremacist yeah by to tan okay
damn you're too tall dude rule number
one about being a white supremacist
they're not short work low bro you know
I'm saying you want to be the guy eggy
you know cuz it's Homewood to get hit
first here's the other thing remember
before you answer Theo has long hair
smooth skin and no tattoos he looks like
a lady carry on
answer Wow I think the only way Theo
survives is yeah the way keep from
sucking [ __ ] don't say that kind of
stuff at the end at the end of the night
he starts telling one of his steel
stories before they rape him and every
was like oh finish your story and he's
like I'll finish tomorrow tomorrow
finish your story than the next leg
that's it again I don't think I'll be on
something either one of us to do very
well in prison no do you would be a
little [ __ ] Christmas turkey in
prison boy yeah dude I kind of know how
to fight gonna be that's how I pictured
prison going for you the first minute
[Applause]
but you can't go 40 seconds without
talking about another man blowing
another man dude now when I look at you
also yeah imma shhh but baby look I'm
sweating like I'm going to prison yeah
what you're saying cuz you can't even
handle the question you can't handle the
truth boy yeah I'll admit I wouldn't do
well better than this guy say that first
of all you are bigger than me bro your
butt is bigger than me and your behold
your B hole is bigger than mine your
mouth is bigger than mine and your nose
it's very feminine yeah but you can't my
nose nobody's gonna they're not like Oh
who's that sexy rabbit with thank you
grab your here come on bro
yeah dude you're going down bro yeah I
might get shanked
at least I'm like getting butts in my
face yeah butts in what your dick no
dude I got take it there man people are
putting butts in your day I don't know
yeah I've never been a prison dude
yeah isn't my problem is I don't know
who decide with it's a race war in there
I'm so blacks don't like me I look kind
of Mexican but I'm not mixing I don't
speak Spanish
bro whites don't like me yeah you're
that tall Mexican little [ __ ] fun
bunny that's all you know ones are we
going fun buddy they're looking at you
going that's a fun rat come on stay with
long hair and a [ __ ] big old bottom
lip that thing's got the bubonic plague
that's what they're saying they're not
gonna be coming at me what do you think
cat come on cat who's who survive in
prison I feel like people would bum-rush
Brendon and that I think Theo would get
away with slinging Goods like ramen like
I feel like he'd be resourceful like
Terry Crews in The Longest Yard
he's that
who could get you McDonald okay so
you're saying that Brendan would
definitely get attacked well you would
be like a meet-up for dicks no no she's
not saying that raped me she's saying
they would kill me
are you think yeah they're not run a
train on me they run the train is gonna
be super friendly to you and then slowly
like that's just a [ __ ] and they see
you know oh wow okay it's just with my
mouth oh you can clean that out with my
mouth for sticky buns okay you want a
Twinkie now to my but that's how bread
then it's slowly it's a snowball of
gayness in prison Jesus Christ dude
you're just really different than you
used to be don't ask you about prison
bro if you don't wanna know the truth
you can't handle the truth
oh I already use that there's like two
minutes yeah well you can't handle the
truth and you can't handle crunchy
peanut butter so we're survive in prison
mates crunchy I'd say there's bumps in
the road I converted you to crunchy
bumps in the road Thank You [ __ ]
autobiography bro here's what I'm saying
is this
you think if Brendan's gonna get killed
in prison cat first of all being awesome
they're gonna have sex before they kill
you no they're not they're not
psychopaths and their prisoners they're
not librarians there's still people Theo
you're an idiot sorry you're not an
idiot but you pretty much also are one
you're an idiot if you don't think
you're your mouth is gonna rape within
two minutes of Brendan dude can we get
to the next thing this is to get this
guy is
yeah yeah boy in the boys all right
yeah you're right baby Eve
hell yeah it was a greatest video
submission of all time shoutout to that
dude well we I think we yeah eiseley
slam from that guy I think you're like
that money from back in the day I was
like my old deal you turned a new leaf
now Oh get your drugs out of his face
bro
yeah yeah yeah that hog on him boy you
see that fork sausage that wouldn't turn
bro for you bro that's that farmer Jon
Hamm dude this one's easy for me I don't
like the urinals like I was just at the
mall I like the urinals because you can
see everyone's [ __ ] up to you no I'm
saying you can peep and see everyone's
dick well I think I liked a little bit
of privacy and we've talked about this
before if you look at other parts of
people's bodies you don't see their dick
you know like if you look at somebody's
eyes or you know their face or chin
shoulders legs feet hands elbows yeah my
steps back smaller the back row teeth
there's way more places to look so if
you're looking at people's dicks you're
gonna see them but you can't make eye
contact bro yeah you shouldn't be
because you're all peeing together
yeah but yes straight forward like a
goddamn psycho I like to see what's
going on I'm also I'm I think it's the
movie True Lies like two bad guys and
come behind me so I'm looking at the
reflection in the little metal part
coming off I'm worried someone's gonna
attack so what I like to do I like to go
in the in the in the with the privacy
one I like to just show them I got that
super soaker
I [ __ ] pump into that thing is really
fast and hard hard like a super soaker I
want everyone to know I'm bringing that
[ __ ] or not though I hate the guy
that does that he goes in there any
pieces fast and as hard as you can yeah
or smear oh and do you take your time oh
dude I will piss for two and a half
minutes brother I'll make a plant in the
hallway jealous brother
I'd rip all day they're like who is that
guy you know give that guy the hydration
system is he on road I go yeah through
filtered I heard one guy say man is that
filtered uwt that Fiji one I'll say this
a urinal no thank you
okay first of all it's like a gangbang
on a drain it's like oh can this drain
it's yes it's a lot and then there's
always that [ __ ] who writes on the
wall yeah like with the phone numbers
there's graffiti on the wall
there's always something nasty on there
but I like to go in and out bro cuz you
want to be there for too long cuz
homeboy next she's [ __ ] dropping
Osama bin Laden
yeah I mean I don't mind being in a
bathroom for a long time so I guess you
have to be you know we're kind of from
different sides of the track when it
comes din there I got a question for
Brendan when you're peeing in the stall
are you lifting up the toilet seat or
are you leaving piss on the sea I next
person to sit down in because I've
rousted two people and they're all
building for doing that case by case
case by case if I'm at if I'm at the gas
station get the [ __ ] out of my face
write it down
man if it's at a nice place like I'm at
the Grove or something I know it's a
nice bathroom some dudes been holding
that [ __ ] in all day and he's after me
I'll lift that seat case-by-case yeah
that's a good call I'll respect the
case-by-case on the on the toilet seat
now I had an issue one time I was trying
to get um a little bit of gas and they
and so I went into the urinal and was
one of those you know that a couple
urinals in there you know it's like a
family style and in the bathroom I mean
and while I was in there some nutcase
came in there you know some deviant and
it was a hitchhiker I think or some guy
that just you know wasn't going you know
didn't care where he was going standard
yeah he came in there got feces out of
his body right rubs it on the door in
everywhere loss to get out so now I'm
trapped into this [ __ ] dude who
spackled us into the room right Wow so
now [ __ ] gingerbread
yeah yeah talked into the room bro they
had to bust out the window and get us
out through there oh yeah this yeah mama
oh man it was just ah [ __ ] VIPRE dis
attack [ __ ] vibrant it's case by case
room so it's case by case but look I'm
not afraid to be at a urinal if some of
the guys there are nice guys I don't
like pissing around mean geezer or if
they're bugging me the other thing too
about that privacy of the the big bowl
sometimes you want to play a game some
won't come in there horrible diarrhea
and spray the sides and then you can
knock that down with your penis
get down I caught it's like it's kind of
like a art or a video game spaceship
with your piss do everyone is looking so
weird or not you know what urinals
I will never well look I cannot believe
I'm talking to a man who urinates on top
of other dudes Dookie dude sometimes
that happens this case my face bro you
haven't been on the road enough then
you're in a road die half bro it happen
I pissed on a lot of things in my life
okay a BIST indoors outdoors objects off
buildings moving vehicles dude a pistol
I try to all pissed on myself in a jet
once sure but I've never urinated on top
of another man see then you ain't livin
brother and I we got I'm glad to be I
can see why what are you talking about
oh oh you've been on set
are they remaking hook no I'm remaking
oh you know bang Ray Rufio from hook
hang a rang bro hang a ring Rufio what
are you talking about my handicap
impalement
your iPad yeah I have one an eyepatch
dude I'm challenging myself because a
lot of everybody's always running around
with two eyes look at you guys look at
him [ __ ] with both of his eyes Oh
bunch of [ __ ] weasels bro and it's
time for you guys to step it game up and
challenge yourselves you know have you
ever heard of the guy who fights with
one hand behind his back nope well there
is that guy he's around and that's who I
am right now and I got this eyepatch on
and I'm rolling on one today dude you
know what I'm saying I'll [ __ ] all y'all
up with one eye bro yeah man yeah yeah I
guess it's cool I figured you came off
the set of hook the remake or Pirates of
the Caribbean
you're like an extra
in your Johnny Depp spark dude there's
somewhere like Jack Sparrow side row
there's nobody up here but there's oh do
I have to realize it sorry you know you
got full Hollywood I'm sorry I was even
talking to you what'd you say I'm on the
cup no it's my agent
yeah we're live Wow Rokon set for what
hey comes with a [ __ ] bedazzled
eyepatch in ear buds Wow bro you got to
go hard these days you know you got to
challenge yourself and I tell that to
everybody all you young men out there
and young women and and people in the
middle of them you know mixed crotch bad
boys out there what I'm saying is this
challenge yourself okay
tie one of your legs behind your back
you know put it um
tuck your dick between your legs and
Bulldog your nuts yeah for a day yeah
for yeah they live check it out walk
backwards you know what I'm saying do an
eyepatch tie one of your hands so your
mouth shut
yeah glue one of your arms to your side
do different stuff and challenge
yourself don't just be doing what you're
doing all the time man it's inspiring
thank you very much man I appreciate it
bro it's that Rat King boy you know some
time that you know I don't need two eyes
bro you could not and I'm trying to
clown it you could not look any more
like the real-life Rat King from Ninja
Turtles he has an iPad really I think so
yeah not something over his eyes oh dude
I'm devolving right into true life I
mean real racket MTV's new series it's
getting bad here and now some over his
eye yeah he had some real he had some
issues - oh wow similar his legs do
bring the two very nice legs but no I
look I'm just yeah look shit's getting
hectic out there you know and I'm ready
I'm training for the end of the world
the guy bus did pool toy repair dude
it's not a big business that was the
problem it's not booming but yeah I say
lip injections I say no it just means I
don't know Theo even if you have that
little twizzler for an upper lip I'd
rather see that [ __ ] Lester Holt you
know
and Lester hold if you was a real crime
honor you [ __ ] track down your upper
lip dad
and I'll [ __ ] say that I think I've
said it before oh and Lester is good
zero upper lip [ __ ] bro yeah you don't
tell me you'd look a thousand times
better with two lips with two lips like
Helia was one like someone bit off the
top yeah I used with some [ __ ] in the
early nineteen she bit off his top lip
oh yeah with shamwows ex-girlfriend it
looks like he had a little bit of maybe
too much coke one time that [ __ ] hard
hitter coaches and chomped his own rip
it off himself yeah I thought it was
foot yeah that front piece I just feel
like gotta have some lips bro that
[ __ ] top soft bumper I don't think
you have anything heavy though do if you
kiss a girl that have those injections
it's like it's like trying to eat a
piece of hard sushi no no not if you do
it right you talk about that eel no not
if you do it right though man if you do
it right we go to a good doctor they
look good what's not boys Mattie match
man
I'm wrote you this song for the King and
the sting a beautiful skimping that you
like it enough to use it look at the
veins in his own
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow I know Octavia Spencer Rohit in the
mock tape all right
Celine Dion in this [ __ ] on the beach
dude how is that not the official song
how is that not our official intro